foreign
let's go to my home state of Texas and
talk to Renee what's up Renee
hey Dr John how we doing
pretty good how are you we are just
we're getting through this one today man
it's been a tough one yeah that was a
rough call that was hard man hard hard
stuff what are you up to
oh man Dr John so the reason I'm calling
I'm just I am so just like at a point
where like I need to make some decisions
but
but um
well
my parents they're like really
they're very kind of old-fashioned
traditional I'll get into some backstory
later but I've been uh dating my
boyfriend for almost four years now and
um
he's he's great it's it's the best
relationship I've ever been in and
um you know he's awesome he's great
um my sisters have met like my sister
has met him my friends have met him but
I have not told or introduced him to my
parents does he have seven arms or Mercy
like is he like uh I don't know
why are you hiding him
well one is just because kind of listen
to you look at you you come out swinging
hey hold on now why why are you hiding
him like what why are you hiding him
well we have a 21-year age Gap okay how
old are you
I'm 31.
dang what who cares all right so you're
31 you're dating 100 year old so what
oh I know it's like how much fun you can
have he's almost retired already
Renee I'm totally messing with you like
why are you hiding him
um I'm just really like just
particularly nervous like like my
parents are so like they're the source
of a lot of anxiety
they've just been very they're very
old-fashioned I was I grew up in a very
strict uh religious household
um I mean like they were very very
strict like even up until my 20s there
could be borderline controlling do you
got a job now
yes I do okay it sounds like and you and
I could get into this for a long time
it sounds like
um
they still have a control over you
whether it's emotionally or
psychologically or spiritually of some
sort
like you're gonna have to let them go
they don't get a vote doesn't matter
for some reason they still have a
powerful hold over you
you're 31 years old
you're a grown woman
and they don't get a vote and what I'll
tell you is just because they don't get
a vote doesn't mean you're disrespectful
and doesn't mean that you don't love
them that means they no longer get to
speak into the actions and day-to-day
decisions of your life now if they're
good parents they're still going to
complain and give you wisdom and be like
I wouldn't do that that's fine that's
what parents do
yeah but they don't get a vote
and you've been holding their voting
card for four years
and what's wild about that is that card
weighs about 10 000 pounds and you've
been dragging it around
and you have for some I mean not for
some reason I know why it's hard and I'm
making it sound so simple but
but you have dragged around a 10
000 pound cinder block
called parents opinion
on boyfriend for four years quit
carrying it
quick hearing it
right right right
they don't get a vote
if they choose to not love you anymore
because of who you love then they've
made a choice
and it will be hard it'll be
heartbreaking and it'll be devastating
but it won't be as heavy as Dragon
around a ten thousand pound
cinder block
okay and in some ways it will be freeing
and if they hold money over you they can
keep their inheritance and if they hold
well the Christmas present they can keep
their Christmas presents
if they think so little of the daughter
they raised
that they are going to disassociate with
her over this then you clearly know
where you stand with them right
right exactly now if they if they give
you their wisdom and they're like we
don't think it's a good idea but we love
you and support you that's fine that's
what parents do if they say hey it's
going to take us a minute all right we
get some time
and we have this conversation with kids
who come out I mean we have this
conversation with all all different
kinds of people parents do get a minute
I give them that like I had a picture
that I had of what Christmas and
Thanksgiving was gonna look like and
that picture is gonna be different now
one because you're bringing a senior
citizen home to I'm just kidding I can't
help it I can't help it lots of people
can't help it listen you're my friend
and I like to climb on my friends
but like you know what I mean like it's
going to be different than the picture
they had there's a shock so be it it is
it is
um and I probably wouldn't just show up
and be like Tada here's Darren I
wouldn't probably do that
from calling what how do I like break
this to them like I mean I have an idea
it's not
a breaking it
can I be real honest with you I've been
holding back a little bit can be super
honest yeah go ahead give it to me
straight you're ashamed of him
no yes you are
I am not ashamed you're ashamed of him
and you're ashamed of you
otherwise you would walk through the
middle of that front door and be like
this is who I am and this is who I love
tell me I'm wrong
um I was I I definitely want to say
you're wrong I'm just really really
behavior is a language my friend
behavior is a language and what you are
telling me by how you act is it you love
this dude but you want to keep him
behind the curtain
because he's got old gray hair
and he probably still wears pleats on
his pants
no
that's just how they ruled in the early
80s do what I mean my friends have met
him my sisters met him and he's met
pretty much everyone except them just I
know but you're talking about him like
he's a like he's a
like my my wife has met my boss
my my wife I mean my my co-workers have
met my kids like you're talking about
him like he's uh
a display
right he's a part of your life
and after four years quite frankly he's
a part of you y'all are together
right
right
so it's not like a big reveal
I mean it is be honest at four years the
reveal is the deception
yeah exactly right and so
I I would honestly call my mom and dad
if you live down the street from him I'd
go visit him or
um otherwise I'd call him on the phone
and say hey here's the thing I've kept
this from y'all and that's on me but
I've been dating this dude for three and
a half four years and I love him and
he's awesome and he's a thousand years
old
and I and it's not traditional and it is
what it is you know what I mean
yeah and I wouldn't go into and if you
can't accept this but oh let them be
grown-ups
and maybe they'll surprise you
maybe they'll surprise you probably they
won't you know your parents pretty well
right
oh yeah yeah and if they throw a fit you
can say I'm not asking
for your permission I'm not asking for
is this the right thing
I'm telling you this is the person I've
been with for four years
we'd like to come to dinner
you see what I'm saying I'm taking all
the air out of everything I'm not
walking in there with it with 25 filled
up balloons
right
I'm walking in there empty-handed and if
they choose to ask me to leave they
think she's asking me to leave if their
behavior chooses it tells me that they
don't want me there then that's that's
heartbreaking and sad and I'll be
um
I'll have to grieve the the crap out of
that but I'm Gonna Leave right because
you don't get a vote this is who I love
and it may come with consequences you
may lose your inheritance or lose the
ranch or whatever the thing is
right and then you've got choices to
make but yeah
if you're not the one with the problem
with the relationship
do you have a problem with a
relationship
no not at all
um I don't have I have zero problems I
mean one of the reasons I've been kind
of so uh just really thinking about kind
of how well I need to tell them I need
to tell them because we are ready we
have made we've had plenty of serious
discussions about our future and we're
kind of ready to take that next step but
um what's the next step
we like to get married one day
um but obviously like neither of us
wants to do that without first obviously
kind of interacting and getting to know
my folks and all of that does he feel
weird does he feel weird that you
haven't taken him home yet
yeah he definitely feels weird if I was
him I would I would I would be weirded
out I would think you're ashamed of me
when I was dating my wife I had real
long hair and it was dyed different
colors and I think I had five earrings
just I was had tattoo I was just an
idiot okay
and when she was taking me home she said
look
this is good
you are not going to be like the other
people I've brought home
and I was in my 19 year old or 20 year
old indignation oh yeah this is just me
I was such a poser I was such an idiot
but
um here's the thing she said you gotta
take all the earrings out
and I need you to comb your hair regular
like a normal person
and I really cared about her and so I
did
and her family gave me a hard time as
they should have
and they're some of the most incredible
in-laws you can ever imagine
my fear is that for four years you've
you've just demonstrated to this guy
that
um you have to hide him
right and my fear is for four years
you've communicated your parents I don't
trust you I can't trust you and that
might be well earned
and for four years you've treated him as
a museum ornament that you introduced to
people
but there's this life thing happening
all around you
and it's got to be exhausting juggling
all that doesn't it
absolutely yeah
uh I forgot the name of the character
but it's from the movie Frozen just let
it go
oh oh yeah don't hold it back anymore
Let it go right right cool same team
that's cool same team now you know this
you call your parents you have this
conversation it could explode yeah
yeah think about how freeing it would be
I would feel great all right so either
way you win if they welcome them in
they're like great we can
I was gonna say something mean
I was gonna say that looks so mean can I
say it it was pretty funny
what if that happened happens that was
that was not very nice joke but it could
have it probably won't happen but they
could get along great
they probably won't but they could
either way you don't have to carry this
thing anymore you can set it down
Fair that's true and then your parents
get to decide are we willing to lose one
of the most precious and extraordinary
women
that we've ever known
because her boyfriend doesn't look like
the picture we had in our head
they get to make that choice not you
moving forward
consider all the ways that you can
become congruent and have integrity
everywhere
good for you guys
four years is a long time
it's fantastic and I'm glad that you got
friends at harassing you that's
fantastic
um they can bring some humor to the
situation because it's hard it's heavy
and it's different
but at the same time
live free you're worth that you are
worth that